So you know,
now I want to talk about postmodernism a
little bit.
Well,
it seems to me that's my youth,
Michel Foucault in the Middle,
and the more reprehensible individual
you could partly ever discover or even
dream up,
no matter how twisted your imagination
and a food co and Dera Dahlia would say,
there's more,
but I would say they're the two
architects of the,
of the,
of the postmodernist movement,
and in brief,
I think what they did was in the late
sixties and early seventies,
they were avowed Marxist some way low
way after anyone with any shred of
ethical decency had stopped being a
Marxist by that time,
even John Paul Sartre and woken up
enough to figure out that the Soviets
hadn't ushered into the Kingdom of
Heaven.
Now he had evidence stretching back 45
years that he could have attended to if
he would have been willing to open his
eyes,
talk about bad faith,
which was his ethical critique.
Essentially.
It's something quite staggering.
The postmodernists knew that they were
pretty much done with regards to pushing
their classic Marxism by the late
sixties in the early seventies because
the evidence that Stella Russia not only
Stalinists,
certainly lennon was no,
no saint by any stretch of the
imagination.
That killing certainly got underway
while he was still alive and and
continued after Stalin was dead as well,
although perhaps with not the same
degree of brutality and efficiency.
And then there was a course Mao's China
where the estimates,
you know,
nobody knows how many people died under
mile,
but the estimates are run as high as
$100,
million people,
which actually turns out to be quite a
few people in the fact that we can't
keep count accurately without an error
margin of something in the tens of
millions just tells you exactly how
horrible the situation was.
They transformed the Marxist dialogue of
rich versus poor into oppressed versus
oppressor and Fuko in particular,
who never fit in anywhere and who was an
outcast in many ways and a bitter one in
a suicidal one his entire life.
Did everything he possibly could with is
staggering Iq to figure out every
treacherous way possible to undermine
the structure that wouldn't accept him
in all his peculiarity and it's no
wonder because there would be no way of
making a structure that could possibly
function if it was composed of people
who were as peculiar,
bitter and resentful as Michelle Foodco,
so you couldn't imagine this functioning
society that would be composed of
individuals with his particular makeup.
In any case,
he did put his brain to work trying to
figure out a way how to resurrect
Marxism under a new guys,
let's say,
and B,
how to justify the fact that it wasn't
his problem,
that he was an outsider.
It was actually everyone else's problem
and he did a pretty damn good job of
that.
Laid the groundwork for this,
for the,
what would you call it,
the rise of the marginalized against the
center and is thinking is very much the
same.
You know,
Derek,
even though my fuco and Derrida hated
each other and regard each other as
intellectual charlatans,
which was about the only thing either of
them was ever really correct about,
so Derrida was also dared in some ways
is even more treacherous thinker because
he makes the claim in some sense that I
a political system has a center around
which the majority congregate.
Let's say it's,
it's,
it's quite similar to food co's analysis
and that there are,
there are people who are outside the
category system and then which is
obviously true because no matter how you
categorize people,
there are certain people inside the
category and certain people outside.
That's actually why you categorize
things,
right?
Because if every category holds every
entity,
then every,
every cognitive operation is infinitely
complex.
You can't manage that way to categorize.
You have to include an excluded.
It's the very nature of categorization
and you can't just scrap categorization
because without simplification and
categorization,
you actually can't function in the
world.
You just die,
right?
You die of excess stress.
It's something like something like that
happens to schizophrenia people because
their category systems break down and
they're completely incapable of
functioning in the world as a
consequence of that.
Anyways.
Um,
then you know,
uh,
Derrida went and flew co as well,
went a step farther and this is one of
the incredibly crooked elements of their
thinking.
I think another slight of hand which was
well category systems exclude political
systems,
exclude economic systems,
exclude any hierarchy of value.
Excludes obviously because if there is a
hierarchy of value,
some things are more valuable than
others and the less valuable things are
excluded because otherwise it wouldn't
be a hierarchy of value.
But the next claim they essentially make
is that the reason that those
hierarchies of value are constructed
isn't to produce whatever it is that's a
value,
but to exclude and to maintain the
structure of power that's intrinsic to
the hierarchy of value.
And that's a,
that's an unbelievably crooked claim
because there are multiple reasons why a
hierarchy of value might be put into
place there.
Hierarchies of beauty and there's
hierarchies of competence,
hierarchies of intelligence and and
attractiveness and,
and athletic ability and musical talent.
There's multiple hierarchies.
And in order for those things to exist
at a high order,
in order for us to,
to,
to laud,
what would you say?
Musical genius.
We have to excuse all the people.
We have to exclude all the people who
can only squawk their clarinet from the
hierarchy because otherwise you don't
have any music and there's no option.
There's no direction.
And so to claim that the purpose of the
hierarchy is to exclude is unbelievably
crooked and it's central claim for both,
for both Fuko and and Dera.
That's one of those slights of hands
that people don't quite notice,
but that have absolutely catastrophic
effects.
Now for food co and Derrida,
you could,
here's how you could imagine their world
essentially.
Um,
you know,
for the,
for the philosopher Hobbes,
life was nasty,
brutish and short,
and people were at each other's throats
in the state of nature,
right?
But Hobbs really thought about that as
a,
as a,
as the chaos of individuals.
And he believed that a central authority
had to exert force in order to organize
that intrinsic chaos so that some degree
of peace could rain.
It's kind of the opposite of John Shaw
crusoe's theory,
which was that human beings were
intrinsically good and,
and the state the government was
intrinsically bad,
and that all of what made people evil
derive from the state.
Um,
I would say if you put hobbes and
Rousseau together,
you actually get the truth,
even though they do seem to be coming at
it from opposite perspectives because
people are actually good and evil and
social structures are also good and
evil.
And you know,
it's paradoxical and we don't like
paradoxical categories,
but that's still how it is.
What,
what Fuco and Derrida and the
postmodernists did was that they kind of
added the collective element to that.
So there are hobbsy and world isn't a
world of individuals struggling against
one another in the initial state of war,
like nature.
It's,
it's groups of individuals bound by
whatever their identity happens to be
struggling against each other for power.
Because in the postmodern,
neo Marxist universe,
there's nothing but power.
And there's a variety of reasons for
that.
Partly it's because the postmodernists
don't admit that there are any standards
outside of arbitrary opinion,
essentially they don't really believe in
the real world,
which is why they can generate critiques
of science,
for example,
which is increasingly characterized is
nothing but part of the euro centric
patriarchies,
um,
what would you call desire to impose
their power structure on the rest of the
world despite the fact that it also
makes planes fly and computers operate
and,
and well,
you know,
yeah,
exactly.
So,
and it's a rare bloody,
um,
social justice warrior that doesn't have
an iphone or a android,
that wouldn't work if quantum mechanics
wasn't actually correct because the fact
that quantum mechanics is correct is one
of the reasons why these unbelievably
highly developed pieces of technology
actually functioned.
So they bitch and whine about the
patriarchal,
patriarchal underpinnings of Eurocentric
Science and use the gadgets all the time
to aggregate,
to complain about it.
So it's really pretty appalling.
So anyways,
anyways,
the worldview of the,
of the postmodern neo marxists is that
everybody is basically not an individual
because that's really a fiction.
And a eurocentric,
patriarchal fiction at that,
but a member of whatever their identity
group happens to be and there's no real
possibility of communication between
identity groups,
hence phenomena like cultural
appropriation.
And so it's a war of all groups against
all groups and it's all,
it's nothing but a struggle for power
and there is no higher order ethic to be
referred to because for the
postmodernists,
um,
there is no such thing as a higher order
ethic.
There is no such thing as a uniting
narrative.
That's,
that's a hallmark of their thinking.
Now,
of course,
that doesn't work out in practice
because without an ethic or a higher
order value,
there isn't anything you can do with
your life because you keep undermining
yourself.
If everything's just a whim and
subjective,
there's.
And there's no hierarchy of values than
what the hell do you do when you get up
in the morning,
if one thing isn't better than the
other,
you might as well just lay there and
smother yourself with a pillow would be
a lot easier than opening your eyes and
struggling in the world.
So it's so it's completely,
it's a self defeating philosophy and I
think that's part of the reason why it's
more or less self evident that it's a
mask for the continuation of Marxism
because at least Marxism has as one of
its advantages at direction.
It's an ethic,
right?
Do you have something to struggle
against even though what you're
struggling against is certainly one of
the things that you actually rely on and
second something that you have to
oversimplify in a very ungrateful and
resentful way to justify fighting
against it to begin with.
And that's especially true in western
cultures because as pathological as they
certainly are,
which is approximately as pathological
as all of you are,
there are a lot less pathological than
almost everything that's ever happened
and pretty much everything that's
currently happening elsewhere in the
world.
And you can kind of tell that by the
fact that people tend to come to
immigrate to the West rather than the
reverse.
Now,
you know,
the postmodern new Marxists would have
an answer to that,
which would be the only reason the west
functions is because it's raped the rest
of the,
of humanity and the planet.
But,
you know,
uh,
the less said about that,
the better.